so let's do another curvature example
this time I'll just take a
two-dimensional curve so it will have
two different components X of T and Y of
T and the specific components here will
be t minus the sine of T t minus sine of
T and then 1 minus cosine of T 1 minus
cosine of T and this is actually the
curve if you watch the the very first
video that I did about curvature
introducing it this is that curve this
is the curve that I said imagine that
it's a road and you're driving along it
and if your steering wheel gets stuck
you know you're thinking of the circle
that you trace out as a result and at
various different points you're going to
be turning at various different amounts
so the circle that you your car ends up
tracing out would be of varying sizes so
if the curvature is high if you're
steering a lot radius of curvature is
low and things like that so here let's
actually compute it and in the last
example I walked through thinking in
terms of the derivative of the unit
tangent vector with respect to arc
length but in this case instead of doing
that I'd want I just want to show what
it looks like when we take the explicit
formula that looks like X prime times y
double prime minus y prime times X
double prime and then all of that
divided by all of that divided by X
prime squared plus y prime squared and
I'm writing X prime and y prime and such
and all of these you should think of as
taking in the variable T I'm just being
a little too lazy to write it and you
take that to the three halves power so
this was a formula and I'm not a huge
fan of like memorizing formulas and then
hoping to apply them later I really do
think the one thing you should take away
from curvature is the idea that it's the
derivative of the unit tangent vector
with respect to arc length and if you
need to you can just look up a formula
like this but it's worth pointing out
that it's makes some things easier to
compute because finding the tangent
vector and everything can be kind of
like reinventing the wheel when you
already have the result here so first
thing to do is just find X prime Y
double prime Y Prime and X prime so
let's go ahead and write those out
so the first derivative of X of T if we
go up here that's t minus sine of T so
it's derivative is 1 minus cosine of t
minus cosine of T and the derivative of
the Y component of 1 minus cosine T Y
prime of T is going to be a derivative
of cosine is negative sine so negative
derivative of that is sine and that one
goes to a constant and then when we take
the second derivatives of those guys so
maybe change the color for the second
derivative here X double prime of T so
we're now we're taking the derivative of
this which actually we just did because
by coincidence the first derivative of X
is also the the Y component so that also
equals sine of T and then y double prime
is just the derivative of sine here so
that's just going to be cosine cosine of
T so now when we just plug those four
value values in for Kappa for our
curvature
what we get is X prime was 1 minus
cosine of T multiplied by Y double prime
is cosine of T cosine of T we subtract
off from that Y prime which is sine of T
sine of T multiplied by X double prime
so X double prime is also sine of T so I
could just say sine of T squared and the
whole thing is divided by X prime
squared so X prime was 1 minus cosine of
t minus cosine of T squared plus y prime
squared so Y prime was just sine so
that's just going to be sine squared of
T and that whole thing to the power
three-halfs
and that's your answer right that you
apply the formula you get the answer so
for example when I was drawing this
curve and kind of telling the computer
to draw out the appropriate circle I
didn't go through the
tire find the unit tangent vector
differentiate it with respect to arc
length process even though that's you
know decently easy to do in the case of
things like circles or helixes but
instead I just wait to that formula I
looked it up because I had forgotten and
I found the radius of curvature that way